there is a way out that there is a way
to do more to get more to obtain more
but I personally don't want to lose all
that I've been able to get so I need to
make sure that I do everything to keep
it so I can't be content mmm so there is
an understanding but I refuse to click
on the switch of so even if you like
even if you have more money than you'll
ever spend for the rest of your life
that's not what it's about it's about
the inspiring people and the influence
and constantly giving back and moving
forward in a positive way and the only
way you can do that is to stay active
it's the story man yeah you know we're
we're all writing a book what's your
book look like mmm
what is your fucking book look like like
your life is a book you got a bunch of
chapters in your book but when they
closed that book how good was the book
how good was your book what was the
ending to your book if the ending to my
book can be so amazing because of all
that was done the money all that was
accomplished the first to do the man
that did this he caused a merger between
this because of his commitment and
growth to this the communities were then
given this made education this changed
the way the schooling was Baba Baba gave
books gave computers gave all of the
things that can be associated with you
and your existence become a part of the
chapters in your book so my drive is
about my book I was a New York Times
number-one bestseller
people will be dying they did it right
in another book you ready to vote right
now yeah what's it happened what happens
if you are two-time New York Times
number one bestseller if you get the two
what happens if you get the three hey
man how do books become successful who
publishes them I want to start a
publishing company aren't be publishing
why not
mmm that's the thing all I'm doing is
sparking the awareness and others to go
why might why can't I create why can't I
start why can't I be a business why
can't I be a CEO why can't I be a tech
guru why can't I fucking create cooking
products lotion since there's so much
that some people just don't understand
they can do let me be a spark to show
how much how many different that you
don't have to do just one thing when
it's all said and done my book is gonna
be full of all this shit that Kevin Hart
did cuz I never was content with doing
just one two or three why not Kevin why
are you creating fucking healthy
wellness products why not
I'm big on health and wellness why can't
I why can't I try to create something
that I feel is fucking great and jump
into a space that I'm already in I
already give a hundred percent of me in
this space why not why can't I talk
about financial wealth why can't I go
back and educate those that don't know
why not you got time I make time
well you certainly can but it's just so
unusual that someone dedicates that much
energy and time to giving back and
getting involved with the kind of
projects that you're talking about as
well as be super ambitious with your own
career it makes me happy yeah I could
tell I'm genuinely happy discovery makes
me happy like when you find different
things to be excited about it makes me
happy and it's weird when it clicks and
schooldays to tell you all the time
information is key read these books
there's so much knowledge II fuck that
book got time to read that book I want
to go home goddamn Sonic the Hedgehog oh
god I want to play I'm at level three I
got something to read this book the
information the stuff that was forced
down your throat at a certain age you
just you just may not be receiving it
correctly but then it clicks you may
gain information differently and what
you do with that information
is up to you but people people have
different roles they can go down the
education wasn't my pick of choice it
didn't do it for me but the knowledge in
the common sense that I have naturally
allowed me to gain information apply it
differently
it allowed me to grow smart in so many
different avenues to where I said oh my
god I found my niche I found my talent
and now there's other things that my
talent can take me to I don't have the
all the knowledge and awareness but I
can allow myself people to do that can
teach me because now guess what learning
is cool you know what happened you don't
have to do it anymore right it's its own
you're a kid they force you into this
school who don't want to learn but then
when you get out and you realize like oh
this actually benefits me this is making
me a better person this makes me wiser
it's 100 percent dirty and it's weird
how it happens but when you go oh my god
learning and knowledge is power
mmm fuck they used to tell me this when
I was 10 your quads yes mom
10 11 years old I heard that shit all
the time now I finally get it
damn I'm out to be 40 all this time I
get that goddamn cold but I got it yeah
it hits you at a different time mm-hmm
and when it does be excited about it man
you excited I'm excited about what 50
years I'm just now getting to 40 do you
read books I don't read a lot of books
do you listen to books on tape I have
listened to books you know what let's do
what Tony Robbins he's great Tony's a
like I like his approach to giving
information mm-hmm I like his attitude
in general I like podcasts I like things
that are real and out of presented in
front of me
I like information that I can go to the
source and and touch and talk so I might
and I'm reading a book it's a book that
was recommended by such-and-such and the
person who gave it to me and has
reading that book I learn more about the
individual that I thought I already knew
and now I gain more Michelle Obama's
book great book great fucking book I met
her I talked to her I've been in the
same rooms I've seen her success
what is her book gonna be about mmm or
read a book
Wow I get it I get wise moving all the
units that it's moving
I get why women are reading this book
and walking away feeling better feeling
like they can't I get it
oh wow hmm certain friends Dwyane Wade
wrote a book focused on being a father
his road to becoming a better father
what he went through with his kids
mother how he developed a relationship
than a bond with his sons like nobody
else Wow didn't know that day that's
dope I love how you put it on page
there's certain things that you just
want to know certain books help I
understand why people read books I get
what the information does you know the
book that I'm working on now is all
about the mental approach that you have
with life and people not understanding
that your biggest enemy is you my whole
book is about you battling yourself
people to understand is you against you
the only person that gets in your way is
you
nobody else is you now when you write a
book like this and especially about
something like this this is like the way
you've managed to navigate through life
mhm
art do you do you write it out in essays
do you go do you do you have like bullet
points that you you think about and then
once you have those bullet points you
had then you write on those how do you
do it
I'll show you keep it on your phone it's
all all voice notes and transcripts okay
so because of your time you don't have
you don't have the the time to sit and
actually write mm-hmm so you need
somebody that you can talk to
for hours hours hours on it hey I need a
Hauer block an hour for me I got some
stuff I want to talk to you about keV
what what's that all right book title
ideas subtitle ideas my dedication is my
introductions within my introductions
these are all powerful paragraphs and
things that I've just said that are now
transcript I get to go back and read it
come see here there's no conversation at
all every one of them um no conversation
at all and that's what the Internet has
allowed people to do the Internet has
allowed people to skip steps 1 through
30 there's a lot of people to jump
straight to 100 fuck you cut job off
take a bow you should be dead Oh God
fucking can't stand this whatever the
hate of the anger is when listen when
listen okay when I listen and I can
change I'm not that guy we're doing
these weird things now that people
aren't taking the time to sit and think
through what I've understood is that
what people are doing has nothing to do
with me I should always be a step ahead
because I'm thinking differently because
I'm thinking about myself making myself
better puts me in a position to make
others better be the example not the
problem the best way to take away the
problem is to a lien ate yourself from
it these are this is just thoughts oh
this fucking thoughts I can go through I
just read this is a so you just have
these philosophies in your life and you
just just speak it sit just speak it
dance so now this is all chance qibla
Columbus's that's incredible that's all
fucking transcript this is all Sarge's
go back throughout the day and I read it
and I say this is great this makes sense
this did it let me reword this I mean
make sure that it's all flowing together
and at the end of the day what's my
reason for the book my reason for the
book is to make people better my reason
for the book is to make people
understand yeah we all agree we all
should think that we're great there's no
reason for you to not think that you're
great if you don't think you're great
ask yourself why why don't you think the
highest of yourself
you do people have no no choice but to
follow suit
mmm got no choice but the follow suit
well a lot of people they base it on
their past they base it on the life that
they've experienced up until this moment
makes you better yeah it does make you
better bet it makes you smarter
yeah well as you say it yeah that's
what's interesting about it that's
what's interesting about life you can
hear a guy like you say that and then it
changes your perspective and then you'll
go out and take action that you might
not have taken before I had a 585 on my
SAT confessions I didn't take my
confession they get you 404 put your
name on a paper it's true story Wow I
guessed a BAC a da I did abracadabra all
true stories what a guy
handle my mother's grain a BAC a da I
didn't care because there was a clash
trip that same day I wanted to go great
adventure I was told they're not taking
my SAT seriously but prohibit me from
furthering myself in life that's what I
was told at the moment I said damn maybe
I should have maybe I should have
applied myself maybe I should have did
different when I saw all my friends get
their test scores back and they were
ecstatic eight hundred nine hundred
ninety six TS everybody's going to
college I felt like the biggest idiot in
the fucking world the biggest idiot in
the fucking world because the same
people that I want to rush to go to
great adventure with they had taken an
SAT two week before they already got
their work done hmm they did everything
that was supposed to do so that moment
of fun was real fun for them I was the
only dumbass that didn't prioritize and
take care of my shit so I've known he
wasn't going to Community College
everybody's else off to Villanova Temple
University Drexel University goddamn
I just got left behind why didn't y'all
tell me that y'all did it the week
before how come you only tell me that we
was serious about the college shit
yawning tell me y'all was trying to go
to Temple or Drexel all wait it's
because my life isn't their life they're
they're focused on themselves wow that
they're doing what they're supposed to
do hey jackass
go sit by yourself and figure it out
because that's where you should be
lesson learn any opportunity given
should be taking series from this point
on because if not you can find yourself
feeling just like this it's not I get
down on myself a fucking moment I learn
from it I learned from it
now I got to take a goddamn test you
best believe I'm studying for that
fucking test cuz I don't want to feeling
like I'm the guy mmm that didn't prepare
now I got a story to tell my kids about
what it feels like to be the kid in
class that didn't prepare that's got the
words great when they give all those
grades back but it's because of my
experience I don't look down on those
moments you take those moments you make
the best of them because they're life
lessons it's that simple
you're saying is positive but it's
really just simplicity that's real it's
real it's real and it's your life
experience and it's your life's lessons
100% but the fact that a guy like you
comes out and talks about it like that
that's where it makes it really powerful
because it's not just something that you
learn from but now other people can
learn from your past too that's what I'm
hoping they'll look at themselves and
they realize like we all start from a
different spot you're not saying yeah
this is why I'm so candid I'm so candid
I'm so open they're there there is no
like guys I'm fine with being an open
book I'm fine with the good the bad ugly
I'm fine being flawed I'm fine with all
the things that have happened to me that
have been exposed I'm fine with it all I
don't hide from it I don't run from it I
don't I don't avoid any of it I'm fine
it's all right it's a bed that I made
for myself I happily lay in it and I'll
be fine figuring it out
moving forward son don't stop for nobody
man son don't fucking stop so I'm gonna
be up in the morning regardless the Sun
is gonna be up in the morning the girl
regardless of how I fucking feel and how
depressed I am the Sun is gonna fucking
shine in the morning and the night time
the moon gonna be there and you gonna
look up these days gonna keep going by
so do you let the days go by and look up
and you don't wasted a year doing what
what do you just pick it up all right
figure it out made some mistakes life
goes on
let me figure out life from this point
I'm a life go along type of guy you're a
bad motherfucker Kevin Hart yeah very
very very inspirational and I'm really
glad you came down here and talked about
it I'm I'm I'm more than glad I think
that it took too long actually and this
is the first of what will be many men
I'm for sure I'm a fan too and I just
think what you're doing is not just
inspirational in terms of like what
you've been able to achieve and who you
are but also inspirational and how
you're so dedicated to helping other
people that means a lot to me it's very
it's very motivating it's very powerful
I wanna I want all your listeners know
that it's not it's not Fatah no this is
this is no way it could be you if you
were doing that just for talk and be
like listen just fake it and then become
that guy
I guess you're onto something if you
could do that and just say it and talk
what fucking to forget about whatever
it's fake or not to it